veamos cómo calcular el volumen de un
cono un cono tiene una base circular y
bueno depende como lo quieras ver a lo
mejor como el sombrero de un mago en el
cono a partir de la base circular sale
una superficie que se une en un punto
que se une o también podríamos dibujar
el cono al revés como el cono de un
helado o como los vasos cónicos que a
veces se encuentran en los dispensadores
de agua y las medidas que tenemos que
tomar en cuenta para calcular el volumen
de un cono son el radio de la base
el radio de la base que vamos
a designar por la letra r aquí lo
tenemos el radio de la base y también
tenemos que tomar en cuenta la altura
del cono la altura del cono que sería
esta distancia que tenemos aquí ésta es
la altura h del cono aquí tenemos la
altura h del cono y la fórmula para el
volumen de un cono y es interesante
porque se deriva claramente de la
fórmula del volumen de un cilindro esto
es sorprendente ya sea atractivo el
estudio de la geometría en tres
dimensiones no es tan complicado como
parece el volumen del cono se calcula
como el área de la base y cuál es el
área de la base el área de esta base
circular el área de la base circular es
pi por radio al cuadrado pi por radio al
cuadrado multiplicado por la altura
multiplicado por la altura y si
simplemente multiplicas pi por radio al
cuadro por la altura eso te va a dar el
volumen de este cilindro el volumen de
este cilindro que contiene al cono
eso va a ser el volumen de ese sonido
que contiene al cono va a ser y por
radio al cuadrado así es que si el
volumen lo dejó tan solo como h por ti
por r al cuadrado estaría obteniendo el
volumen de esta lata de este cilindro
pero si sólo queremos el volumen del
cono es un tercio de eso es un tercio de
eso ya eso me refiero cuando digo se
deriva claramente que el volumen de este
cono es la tercera parte del volumen de
este cilindro que lo limita esta fórmula
la puedo reescribir como un tercio de pi
o pi sobre 3 que multiplica a h y que
multiplica a r cuadrada o como quieras
reescribir la la manera fácil de
recordar esto para mí el volumen de un
cilindro es bastante intuitivo
calculando el área de la base y
multiplicando la por la altura obtenemos
el volumen de un cilindro y ahora si
dividimos dicho volumen entre 3 vamos a
obtener el volumen del cono que está
contenido en dicho cilindro esa es una
manera de verlo vamos ahora a usar
números para asegurarnos que sepas
aplicar esta fórmula
supongamos entonces que nos dicen que
este es
un pequeño vaso cónico de papel y nos
indican que contiene
que contiene 131 centímetros cúbicos de
agua también nos indican que la altura
de este vaso cónico la altura de este
vaso cónico déjame hacerlo mejor con
otro color la altura de este vaso cónico
es de 5 centímetros dado eso nos piden
que encontremos aproximadamente el valor
del radio al centímetro más cercano
vamos entonces a aplicar la fórmula
tenemos que el volumen es de 131
centímetros cúbicos que es igual a un
tercio de ti por la altura que es 5
centímetros y eso multiplicado por el
radio al cuadrado
si queremos despejar el re cuadrado
tenemos que dividir ambos lados entre
todo esto para obtener entonces qué
radio cuadrado es igual
131 centímetros al cubo centímetros
cúbicos y eso vamos a dividirlo entre un
tercio que lo mismo que multiplicar por
tres dividido entre sí
por cinco centímetros vamos a limpiar un
poco esto tenemos centímetros en el
denominador y centímetros cúbicos en el
numerador esto nos resulta en
centímetros cuadrados ahora si queremos
despejar r tomamos raíz cuadrada a ambos
lados para obtener entonces que r va a
ser igual a la raíz cuadrada de 3 % 31
son 393 dividido entre 5 por pi dividido
entre 5 por pi
estamos sacando la raíz cuadra de todo
esto y aquí tenemos las unidades que son
estamos sacando la raíz cuadrada de
centímetros cuadrados esto nos da
centímetros lo cual está bien pues el
radio se mide en centímetros y ahora
sacamos la calculadora para ver cuánto
da el valor del radio aprendemos y es la
raíz cuadrada de 393 dividido entre 5
por cinco por pi 5 por ti y esto nos da
igual a esta muy bien
cinco puntos muy cerca de 5 así es que
el valor del radio el valor del radio es
aproximadamente 5 centímetros y así
hemos concluido